population collapse
is uh one of the biggest threats to the
future of human civilization and that is
what is going on right now i'm trying to
say a good example because the birth
rate on earth is so low that we're
facing civilizational collapse unless
the birth rate uh uh returns to su as
sustainable level
well i've thought for at least 10 years
that the biggest problem in 50 years
will be that there's just not enough
people we might be living on earth right
now
at a time with the most number of humans
that are ever going to exist at one time
ever yeah that's highly probable and you
know and the population collapse
in developed countries is precipitous
right it's like at fault we fall off a
cliff i worked on
u.n committee
it's got to be 10 years ago now
to help draft the un secretary's
general's report on sustainable economic
development and so i looked at all sorts
of things like that i was very curious
for example about
because people have been beating the
overpopulation drum since
well it really kicked in in the 1960s
you know because there were dire
predictions by the year 2000 the club of
rome came out and said well there'll be
riots and mass starvation and mass
movement of of migrants and all the
things you hear about climate change
because there's too many people on the
planet and that just didn't happen at
all that was just that it wasn't just
wrong it was anti-true it was absolutely
wrong and so
i looked at population trends and first
of all found
not that this is an act of genius or
anything that as soon as you educate
women
the size of family shrinks precipitously
like below replacement and that's partly
because women have other options all the
countries in the west are way below
replacement korea is way below
replacement south korea japan way below
replacement i think nigeria will have
more people in it than china by the end
of the century
and musk you know he's a far
looking
man
and so he's looking
around the apocalyptic corner let's say
oh we're running out of people and what
that means of course is that you run out
of young people
right you don't run out of old people
first because everyone who is here now
is going to be 30 years older in 30
years and
it'll be young people we don't have
enough of and of course young people are
the ones who do the innovation and are
going to do most of the heavy lifting
etc and so there's going to be a
terrible shortage of young people well
you see this with some of the things
that i i posted that ons data the 50.1
percent of women childless by 30 and
both men and women are replying to that
tweet saying well good there's too many
people on the planet this idea that the
planet has too many people on it this is
there's no
sentiment more implicitly genocidal than
that statement so what do you mean too
many people
exactly and what do you mean the planet
and what do you propose to do about that
exactly mass abortion is that your
answer or should we do something a
little more dramatic maybe we'll just
shame people out of having children and
i've seen people do that literally i saw
a professor when i was at a
it was a number of professors talking to
a couple hundred students and one of the
professors who was an environmentalist
activist type and he got up on stage and
shook his finger to the whole young
crowd saying that him and his wife had
only decided to have one child which was
in my opinion one child too many for him
and
told all the young people there if they
had a shred of ethical decency that they
would lim severely limit their
reproductive potential and
i stood up and said that i thought that
was the most one of the most appalling
things i'd ever heard anyone in academia
say to young people which is really
saying something because they say plenty
of appalling things and it was a very
uncomfortable moment and he huffed off
the stage but
you know in a frenzy talking about how
you couldn't talk about such things
without being pilloried on ethical
grounds and yeah that's for sure
it was just
beyond comprehension it's beyond
comprehension but it's associated with
like a deeply rooted
existential self-hatred
and and i mean hatred at the level of
humanity is like a virus on the planet
that we're a cancerous group we know
where your heart is
located
because what's what's the implications
for for a doctrine like that what do you
do with the cancer
cut it out yeah that's for sure poison
it or whatever whatever there's nothing
you don't do to a cancer so you're gonna
use a metaphor like that there's too
many people on the planet you're gonna
use a metaphor like that
you know and then you're gonna you're
gonna also decide that you're virtuous
while you're using it because you're on
the side of the planet whatever the hell
that means
so yeah it's it's unbelievable and a
huge part of it's rooted in this
existential
shame and horror at the condition of
being human and the fact that life is
rife with suffering and a lot of it's
unjustified and
you know it's a mephistophelean
position so mephistopheles was laid out
portrayed in gurtha's faust
um that's
the story of a man who sold his soul to
the devil for knowledge it's a story of
intellectual pride and
gurtha stands in relationship to german
literature in the same manner that
shakespeare stands in relationship to
english literature
earth is mephistopheles
says straight out twice in in the play
once in the first
there's two books and once in the first
book and once in a second girth that
hasn't restated twice
existence is such a foul thing because
of all its suffering essentially that it
would be better if it was merely enough
annihilated
and that's the mephistopheleon stance
this whole show should just come to a
halt look at how corrupt people are evil
reigns everywhere it's nothing but will
to power we're destroying the planet
with our unchecked ambition all of it
rooted in greed and and and
machiavellianism and jockeying for
position and we're so contemptible that
we should just roll up and die
and we should shame women into not
having children and we should shame men
so they never manifest any planet
destroying ambition and
it's
it's unbelievably appalling it goes all
the way down to the bottom
the bottom of things that's what's
tearing our culture apart this dispute
about
the nature of existence at the most
fundamental level
we have to be smart about our resources
but that doesn't mean there's zero sum
and certainly doesn't mean the world is
a zero-sum game
and that's a malthusian idea you know
that population will grow till it
consumes all available resources and
precipitously collapse
and then why do we think apocalyptically
it's well because things do come to
sudden ends
people die people get fatal illnesses
like the world you so carefully
constructed can be blown apart at any
moment by a random occurrence genetic
mutation that causes the cancer that
kills you like life has a life has a
fundamentally apocalyptic aspect
and we do understand that because we're
self-conscious and then it's very
difficult not to apply that kind of
apocalyptic reasoning to
things as such
the world's going to burn up
the climate's too hot what about runaway
positive feedback loops because that's
what the climate types are afraid of
it's like hey they happen
how do we bind our apocalyptic thinking
that's a good question man
that's a good question we do that
through truth we do that with the truth
that's how we do it through dialogue
through investigation through
exploration
through discipline
all of that the logos is the antidote to
the apocalypse
and so what does that mean well love and
truth is the antidote to the apocalypse
not the planet has too many people on it
i'm trying to set a good example because
the birth rate on earth is so low that
we're facing civilizational collapse
unless the birth rate
returns to
a sustainable level yeah you've talked
about this a lot the depopulation is a
big problem and people don't understand
population collapse
is uh one of the biggest threats to the
future of human civilization and that is
what is going on right now what what
drives you on a day-to-day basis to do
what you do
i guess
like i i really want to make sure that
there is a good future for humanity um
and that we're on a path to
understanding the nature of the universe
the meaning of life why are we here how
do we get here
and in order to
understand
the nature of the universe and
all these fundamental questions
we must expand the scope and scale of
consciousness
certainly it must not diminish or go out
or we we certainly we wouldn't
understand this i would say i'm
motivated by curiosity more than
anything
and
just a desire to think about the future
and
not be sad you know and um
and and are you are you not sad
i'm sometimes sad i i mostly i'm i'm i'm
feeling i guess relatively optimistic
about the future these days
there are certainly um some big risks
that humanity faces
uh i think the population collapse is a
really big deal that i wish more people
would
would think about
because the birth rate is far below
what's needed to sustain civilization
it's current at its current level it's
important to take whatever actions we
can think of to address the existential
risks that affect the the future of of
consciousness
there's a whole generation coming
through who seem really sad about the
future
what would you say
to them
well i think if you want the future to
be good you must make it so
take action
to make it good and it will be
[Music]